[Musique]
face à la première
bienvenue dans notre émission face à la
première comme chaque fin de semaine
diffusé en direct le vendredi à 14 ans
sur notre site internet la première
point fr appui en radio le dimanche à 12
heures
nous recevons aujourd'hui deux femmes
artistes créatrice culturelle des
citoyennes engagées dans leur milieu
dans leur société dans leur pays dans
l'otan
à ma gauche jala bonjour oui bonsoir
vous êtes marionnettiste écrivaine
notamment de livres pour enfants entre
autres vous venu crier votre actualité
mais nous y reviendrons tout à l'heure
avec des amis et associés et nouvelle
entreprise une coopérative dentiste une
formule assez originale inédite en
martinique et nicolas cage à ma droite
mon jour nicolas cage
bonjour bonjour merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation vous êtes dit rice
écrivaine vous venez de publier le
premier de la longue série que l'on
espère en tout cas de vos ouvrages une
anthologie de textes écrits par des
femmes font confiance à votre maison
d'édition et 10 prod cimarron avec un
nom original que nous allons discuter
tout à l'heure vous est également
chanteuse et vous avez été dans une
temps passer par des sites éloignés
professeur d'espagnol
voilà donc nous allons expliquer tout ça
tout à l'heure alors comme d'habitude
dans l'hémicyle dans cette émission
quelques questions d'actualité avec une
question d'actualité je suppose qu'en
tant que citoyenne en tant que mère de
famille tant que personnes engagées dans
lion société vous est environné depuis
quelques jours par les débats la
controverse sur le chlordécone jala mais
claude écoles on en parle beaucoup ces
temps ci mais pour moi ça fait un moment
que ça va commencer puisqu'il ya déjà eu
des publications dessus il ya un petit
peu de scandale avec l'histoire du
professeur belpomme et tout cela au ps
ne voulait rien entendre et ensuite
maintenant bien les gens prennent bien
conscience que le problème est bien là
voilà donc effectivement il faut des
solutions parce que nous je suppose que
notre génération est très bien claude et
connaît depuis les années je sais pas
moi pour moi j'ai 65 ans
et et en tant que bon j'ai été aussi
exploitante agricole et j'ai utilisé ce
produit mais je sais pas encore comment
faire pour savoir si j'en ai dans le
sang comment on fait pour détecter cela
dans le corps humain
puisqu'on sait que l'on a on n'a pas
consommé enfin de la consommer par la
peau par la bouche et tout cela
effectivement je trouve que c'est très
intéressant que chaque dans chaque
domaine par exemple les agricultures les
nutritionnistes chacun dans son domaine
et c'est de porter des solutions puisque
vu comme peut pas l'enlever comme ça de
de la terre on est obligé de consommer à
minima voilà donc que chacun prenne un
peu c'est le taureau par les cornes et
prenne ses responsabilités en attendant
vraiment là dimanche et de l'as le
soulèvement du peuple parce que moi je
trouve que c'est le peuple
la politique c'est la politique mais le
peuple a une décision à prendre a pour
réclamer réparation comme dans d'autres
domaines la responsabilité du peuple est
lourde n'est ce pas nicolas cage vous
adhérez à cette l'idée absolument
absolument c'est vrai que comme le dit
jah là c'est une affaire qui qui date
nous étions je me souviens des premiers
rassemblements contrôlés pendage aériens
contre le chlordécone devant la
préfecture nous étions une poignée de
personnes essentiellement des femmes
toujours les femmes à la pointe des
combats avec nos casseroles et et et
nous fait tout à faire du bruit à faire
du bruit pour qu'on nous entende et pour
que et pour que ce scandale asseoir
soient dénoncés bon aujourd'hui à la
faveur d'un reportage télévisé que je
salue dont je salue l'initiative les
consciences en semble se réveiller c'est
une bonne chose mais maintenant il est
il apporte de 2,2 continuer de désigner
les coupables
et puis 2 2 que les fonds nécessaires
pour la dépollution soit soit soit
engagée par parce que c'est une
c'est un vrai hein une vraie
problématique de de santé publique est
carrément de de survie je pense que ceux
qui parlent de deux génocides n'exagère
pas c'est vraiment un réel problème
auquel est confronté notre peuple et
face à ça je trouve qu'il y aille je ne
dirai peut-être que le mode emma veulent
tirer trop fort mais en tout cas je ne
sais pas s'il ya une prise en compte
réelle de de l'impact de ce ranking
présenté par son papa par le
gouvernement par le gouvernement c'est
vrai que toutes les prises de position
qui ont été prises me semble démesuré à
allonnes de la gravité du problème il
n'y a pas un risque jala que le soufflé
retombe dans quelques centres ça va
encore on est sous le règne d'un seul
empire de l'émotion
comme beaucoup de choses et puis après
quelques jours ou quelques semaines ça
retombe on passe à autre chose je dis on
s'est collectivement la cci en général
le peuple comme vous dites mais
également les politiques et les
responsables gouvernementaux finalement
on attend que beaucoup que l'orage passe
je ne pense pas que ça va passer parce
que il suffit d'aller voir du côté de
clarac on voir tous les méfaits de y
ce fléau est non seulement un clara
couffin et tant d'autres domaines aussi
mais il suffit de voir tous les cancers
peut-être aussi des malformations je dis
peut être si sûr
et tout ce que ça va engendrer je ne
crois pas que ce sera un soufflet qui va
retomber au contraire il faut qu'il a
eue en simplifiant et bien moi je dis
toujours c'est nous 1c nous parce
qu'après bon je suppose qu après le
carnaval les gens auront ce sujet là
puisque bon carnaval les gens ils ont
besoin de se décomplexer de temps il va
ya trois ans de cela 3 carnaval de ça on
arrive c'est un carnaval carnaval
militants le mercredi décembre on était
en en blanc et noir avec nos masques
et pour dénoncer pour dénoncer dans le
vide et en plein coeur du vide et pour
dénoncer le scandale il faut que ça peut
être aussi oui oui avec ses oreilles de
mobilisation mais là le beau gameiro est
beaucoup plus grave c'est un beau
problème de santé
jacob quand on regarde la santé dans
notre pays
bon dans d'autres aussi bon mais moi je
surmonte inique et appelait de problèmes
de matériel de personnel de d'argent bon
on regrette toujours à l'argent donc je
ne pense pas que ce soit un sujet qui va
qui va retomber de sitôt
bien que c'est vrai qu'il ya dix ans il
était retombé comme tu dis grâce à
l'émission c'est revenu sur l'actualité
mais il me semble qu'il ya quand même
d'autres personnes qui qui en parle
aussi parce que c'est ça qui est
important si ces deux trois personnes
qui en parlent ça va pas mais maintenant
quand on verra avec les analyses avec
les scientifiques avec les biologistes
les chimistes parce qu'il faut bien des
solutions pour enlever cette molécule de
la terre et du corps humain donc je
pense je ne pense pas en fait je ne
souhaite pas que ça retombe comme un
soufflé ce n'est pas un effet de mode
pour moi alors avant de venir au coeur
de votre de vos activités multiples et
variées mais dame carla et nicolas cage
dans face à la première aujourd'hui
y at il d'autres motifs comment
dirais-je de mobilisation il y at il
d'autres motifs pour lesquels le peuple
la population devrait se mettre en
couleur ne devrait se mettre en
mouvement ou en tout cas à titre
personnel qu'est ce qui prouve votre
qu'est ce qui fait qu est-ce qui fait
garder intact votre capacité
d'indignation ma capacité d'indignation
je crois qu'elle est qu'il est qu'elle
est là que les encres et quelles étaient
les profondeurs
c'est vrai que ya l'actualité et ce
qu'elle nous donne en pâture j'ai envie
de dire et puis il y avait des problèmes
j'ai envie de dire plus qui sont là qui
sont qui traverse le temps et qui en
tant que femme sait c'est la question
des violences des violences faites aux
femmes et des aides et récurrente les
douloureuses et et c'est un vrai sujet
de préoccupation
comment comment porter sa contribution à
cette lutte comme emporté 7 à
contribution à l'information à la prise
de conscience c'est c'est une c'est une
vraie vraiment une vraie une vraie
préoccupation pour moi en tant que femme
et peep pour moi en tant que citoyenne
de ceux de ce pays la même question jara
si vous deviez vous mobiliser à part les
questions de santé publique comme on l'a
vu quel autre thème quel autre question
vous fait bondir vous irrite vous agace
vous motive à 6 mondial donc moi je suis
quelqu'un mais je vais assez souvent
dans les manifestations passées c'est
vrai qu'il ya beaucoup de préoccupation
par exemple justement comme elle parlait
pour la marche des femmes et tout cela
quand elles font une manifestation
souvent j'y suis on en vient la rue
excentive à chaque fois qu'il ya qui a
des cas bon pour le problème de 2 que le
gouvernement a enlevé les emplois aidés
et à une grosse manifestation aussi à
fort de france
j'y étais chaque fois qu'il ya quelque
chose par exemple pour l'usiné la
biomasse intérêts j'y suis donc bon je
fais aussi partie aussi bien même ses
partisanes delà de la soummam a donc
pour chaque fois qu'il ya un sujet
effectivement on est obligé d'être là
puisque tout ça ça fait partie de notre
vie on ne peut pas choisir bonbons moi
je prends plus sur lui des femmes que
celui de l'autre - tous tous ces sujets
là même se garder que les jours y aura
une manifestation à fort de france
puisque je suppose qu'elle va venir en
état là c'est quoi mon mais en 2002
fossé bon même si j'ai changé de clan
plus tard j'étais salarié après chibani
chefs d'entreprise mais j'étais aussi
aux côtés des des gens qui travaillent
les travailleurs du tout cela tous les
sujets normalement nous sommes dans une
vie tous les sujets nous préoccupent
comme le sujet même si j'ai ma voiture
mais le sujet du transport aussi mais
aussi mettez en paix les problèmes qui
se passe d'un par exemple dans les
partis politiques je ne suis pas j'ai
pas mal côte de parenty du mini de aucun
autre parti puisque aussi bien content
de folie dans une émission politique
alors que je ne fais pas mais nous
vivons dans ce monde là et tout cela
nous nous étions peine nous sommes dans
la vraie vie
merci de ces précisions alors jala mais
je vais rester sur vos expliquez-nous un
peu ce que signifie ce que ce quel est
le périmètre d'activité de
responsabilité de aider à l'espace
d'entraidé de développement d'activités
cette coopérative d'activités et
d'emploi qui compteront regroupe une
quarantaine d'entrepreneurs une demi
douzaine de salariés et qui incombe une
dans quelque sorte de donner une place
un créneau économique à des créateurs
culturels studio un sens très large
oui a lancé pas uniquement culturel
c'est ça on a autant des jardiniers que
cuisinier que que ce besoin ce sont des
gens qui n'ont plus envie d'être chômeur
disons qu'ils ont besoin de créer leur
propre emploi
voilà donc ils viennent à la coopérative
parce qu'ils ont un projet ils viennent
pas chercher un projet ils viennent
parce que ils ont un projet alors c'est
pas une coopérative que j'écris et je
suis gérante depuis cette année voilà
mais c'est une coopérative qui existe
déjà depuis 2005 et au jour
d'aujourd'hui effectivement il ya une
quarantaine de d'entrepreneurs ce sont
des entrepreneurs salariés parce qu'ils
ne créent pas leur entreprise mais ils
sont entrepreneurs et ils ont une fiche
de salaire à la fin de chaque mois et
tout cela puisqu'ils vont ramener un
chiffre d'affaires ils sont payés selon
les ors leur chiffre d'affaires ils sont
à la sécu ils bénéficient de tout ce que
des endroits un salarié cessé quand j'ai
payé ses assedic si si ça n'a pas mangé
c'est une espèce de dopés pignon sur rue
de couveuse
c'est une sorte d'alternative
nouvelle voie entre le chômage le
sous-emploi d'une part et puis l'emploi
salarié classique d'autres parents
absolument et puis celui aussi du chef
d'entreprise parce qu'il ne lit pas il
est entrepreneur mais il n'est pas un
chef d'entreprise et ensuite cet
entrepreneur salarié peut devenir aussi
associé parce que c'est une coopérative
c'est une sarl un capital variable
il suffit que la personne achète du deux
actions et puis elle est associée
après avoir été entrepreneur est certain
temps mais nous avons aussi nous avons
trois collèges et le le parce que nous
sommes aussi ce qu'on appelle une scic
est peut être qu ainsi qu'il faut avoir
3 cuil donc nous avons le collège des
des entrepreneurs des entrepreneurs
salariés
nous avons le collège des employés passe
il ya aussi des employés salariés qui
sont associés voilà et puis nous avons
le clavier des gens de l'extérieur qui
veulent venir et y parlera savoir où et
c'est eva ils achètent des actions ou
bien vingt sept puisque c'est ouvert et
c'est pas cher c'est vrai ou inaction et
puis il y z 2 puisque effectivement
c'est pour même laboratoire nous envoie
du monde donc on travaille avec
plusieurs plusieurs partenaires pour que
les gens puissent assumer sa part comme
jeudi de la femme de mitac marchand de
charbon ou bien des formateurs il ya
tout dedans toute espèce d'autres
repreneurs je vous pose la question
parce que vous êtes une militante
culturelle vous c'est une créatrice vous
êtes une artiste et vous enlevez le
temps la disponibilité d'esprit de vous
occuper de gestion d'entreprise
ben oui puisque pendant plus de 20 ans
moi même j'ai eu mon entreprise que j'ai
géré alors là c'est une question
d'organisation on a pensé aussi à edéa
puisque nous formons nos entrepreneurs à
s'organiser
on fait même et comme un appel un fait
selon leur profession qu'ils veulent
épouser ils ont cette formation puisque
on recherche des formateurs dans
plusieurs secteurs et puis on apprend à
un dizaine on apprend tout ça puisque
c'est lui mais qui est mis en avant
dans cette coopérative alors c'est la
même question que j'ai posée à nicolas
cage qui au départ était professeur
d'espagnol qui est devenu entrepreneuse
vous avez quitté vers les niveaux un
confort relatif à fonctionner en
travaillant avec des élèves leur
apprenant une langue étrangère les
initiant à une culture puisque qui dit
profs de langues également enseigné
initiateur de la culture des pays où et
parler cette langue et vous dit de vous
devenez chef d'entreprise avait
peut-être d'une maison d'édition que
vous avez cru
qu'est ce qui a déclenché cette démarche
c'est ce geste déclenche et déclenche et
ça ça ça sous-entend un peu des montants
élevés l'armée maté et puis bon ok mon
café ça c'est un projet que je portais
depuis depuis depuis longtemps déjà en
fête et il manquait quoi il manquait
manqué de courage il manquait
l'accompagnement il manquait le les
étapes une vision de des étapes à
franchir pour en arriver là
et une fois que j'ai eu tout ça binger
j'ai franchi le pas non sans être passé
par par l'incubateur de matinée
pionnière c'est quelque chose qui a été
important pour moi
abondant dans l'aide à la prise de
décision justement le dernier moment on
se dit qu'est ce que je pense que j'y
vais ce que j'y vais ce que j'y vais et
puis on y va parce que parce que voilà
il y avait cet accompagnement avec des
consultants qui nous qui nous forme est
en fait sur sur le métier de
l'entrepreneuriat au féminin le sceptre
cette formule déjà là me semble
importante parce que avec qu'il ya parce
que
c'est important de ne pas être seul
c'est vraiment important en particulier
quand on est femme de savoir que ben est
conquis un réseau alors je ne suis pas
dans un réseau comme ça que c'est une
c'est une sarl que nous avons crié mais
aussi et moi mais le réseau il est
informel c'est ce sont ceux sont les
soutiens c'est la famille ce sont les
amis c'est c'est un chef d'entreprise
consultants qui me qui me donne un coup
de mer en termes de malades
d'accompagnement jeu je veux parler
d'andré laviolette que l'on connaît plus
sous le nom de chanteau qui est chanteur
et on ne connaît moins comme chef
d'entreprise et donc voilà c'est c'est
donc ce n'est pas un coup de folie oui
détresser même si évidemment il ya des
soirs où voilà le une poussée
d'adrénaline brive bayonne
waouh parce que il y a il ya le bain il
ya le vivre au quotidien et puis à le
fait que vous parler de la dimension
artistique c'est vrai que du coup il y a
moins de temps pour pour la création je
veux dire que par exemple en tant que
maison d'édition il y à là déjà dans
près pratiquement à à l'édition il y à
une quinzaine d'ouvragés déjà et d'un
kit henri iv et harmonium ambassades
keeper aucune itt en fait mais c'est
mais c'est tellement de bonne heure de
balade de ce livre forme qu'on slam
c'est c'est la matérialisation de ce
rêve de rêve que je veux collectif donc
c'était important pour moi de démarrer
cette maison d'édition de signer son
acte de baptême avec un ouvrage
collectif et en particulier un ouvrage
collectif de femmes alors il y a bon dos
risque un prix par le chef de la chef
d'entreprise comme on dit la cheftaine
la chef d'entreprise vont pas vous allez
me dire une entrepreneuse
et puis l'activité artistique culturel
parce que ce sont quand même des
domaines
ne sont pas forcément liés on ne voit
pas trop la liaison forcément quelle
part de vous même en tant que créatrice
cij alain nicole cas jeudi la même
question talent et on devait vous
abandonnez vous mettre entre parenthèses
pour vous occuper justement de faire
vivre cette entreprise parce que ce
n'est pas une mince affaire dans ce pays
où la prise de risque n'est pas si
fréquente notamment sur le plan
économique un indice c'est un chef
d'entreprise
parce qu'il doit mener sa carrière il
doit chercher ses clients avec ses
terrasses et un chef d'entreprise
tout comme une mère de famille est même
une femme au foyer
c'est un chef d'entreprise parce qu'il
faut avoir une sacrée organisation marie
enfant famille etc
nous sommes tous potentiellement des
chefs d'entreprise à mon humble avis bon
mener la carrière artistique
effectivement tout temps et manager une
équipe parce que bon c'est vrai il est
salarié plus des entrepreneurs c'est une
grosse équipe mais ce sont ceux sont
déjà qu'ils sont déjà involontaire les
entrepreneurs dont ils connaissent leur
métier et puis il ya du monde autour
donc ils suffisent comme je disais c'est
une question d'organisation d'abord
depuis janvier que j'ai commencé bon j'y
étais déjà avant puisque quand j'ai mon
entreprise a fermé
j'ai aussi entré à la coopérative j'ai
fait un petit peu le chemin inverse
puisque on suscite plutôt les gens avant
le cahier de l'entreprise devenir un peu
s'initier pour savoir si c'est viable ou
pas j'ai fait le chemin inverse et donc
étant donné bon c'est pour ça d'ailleurs
qui m'ont qui m'ont appelé donc il m'a
proposé cette cette responsabilité c'est
une question d'organisation parce que
jusqu'à maintenant je ne sens pas encore
le bon ça fait pas longtemps mais je ne
sens pas que ti oc ou l'autre il faut
s'organiser c'est tous les mêmes
questions pour une colle cage c'est pas
facile hein comme surtout quand on lance
une entreprise quand
depuis quelques mois seulement est-ce
que ça n'atteint pas 1 votre capacité
créatrice
disons que la créativité va se déployer
sur d'autres modes sur de nouveaux modes
de nouveaux canaux mais elle est là elle
est intacte parce que justement pour pau
fait revivre une entreprise surtout dans
le temps dans le domaine culturel mais
ça prend de la créativité s'apprend de
l'imagination ça prend de la gymnastique
parfois mais mais il y a la motivation
et puis de toute façon il y a toujours
un moment qu'on peut voler pour écrire
pour crier pour écrire une chanson une
mélodie etc etc c'est ces moments là bas
ils sont peut-être moins moins long en
terme de durée mais ils sont peut-être
aussi plus intense et et plus finalement
plus plus porteurs nous sommes dans face
à la première l'émission en politique au
sens très large en l'émission politique
hebdomadaire de martinique la première
sur internet et en radio jala dans notre
société de consommation société de
loisirs n'est-il pas illusoire de
vouloir continuer de créer tout ce qui
se rattache à la culture aux idées à
l'intellect est il encore audible
perceptible mais absolument sinon on est
mort il faut absolument continuer de
crier continuer
non seulement nous bon moi je me situe
dans une corrida je ne dis pas que j'ai
presque fini bon mais j'ai déjà quand
même un certain parcours et c'est pour
ça que j'aime beaucoup l'homme aux
transmissions
parce que bon moi j'ai commencé depuis
le début je faisais toujours des stages
apprenez aux gens ce que j'avais appris
ce que j'inventais ce que je criais et a
toujours ce cette transmission là qui
doit se faire parce que souvent dit bon
untel ou untel paty et puis parti et
puis tout ça était savent je trouve que
maintenant on est 10 plus ça par exemple
nous avons deux valeureux
chanteur et tambouille et qui sont pas
anti eh bien ils sont pas partis avec
tout leur savoir la balade de récemment
voilà donc ils sont pas anti mais tout
en ayant déjà fait le travail de
transmission ce qui ne se faisait pas je
suppose avant un mais avoir aussi
c'était différent parce qu'il y avait
pas de cours ou de beloeil avait pas des
coups de de compte on était un petit peu
initié un c'était désignation que ce qui
se faisait en soit en regardant vraiment
ce que la personne fait et puis
finalement se forment tous ceux dans la
halle ayant regardé mais maintenant il
ya effectivement des des écoles de
pelles et des écoles de deux conteurs
des cols bleus de marionnettes aussi on
apprend dans tous les domaines
maintenant on apprend et non je trouve
que c'est très important déjà ça crée de
l'emploi ça crie ça ce sera nos
richesses culturelles puisque sinon on
ne fut bien c'est tout ce qui vient de
l'extérieur que nous allons adopter
déjà malgré cette résistance chez nous
les jeunes
et puis certains prennent quand même
doxi avait pas un moment ce serait sait
ce qu'est la fin de tout nicolas cage
même question en effet ce qu'il n'y ait
pas risqué de vouloir tout de même cru
et comme dans votre cas est vanté des
chansons vous avez monté des pièces de
théâtre vous écrivez de la poésie vous
éditer des livres maintenant est-ce que
c'est pas quand même illusoire de
vouloir résister aux vents delà de la
consommation et du tout facile c'est
vrai qu'on peut se poser légitimement se
poser la question surtout quand on quand
on voit que sally pas propre seulement
au gouvernement français mais mais
l'ensemble la plupart des gouvernements
en cas de crise entre guillemets parce
qu'on peut s'interroger sur le sur la
réalité de ces crises belle et les
premiers
les premières coupes sont elles se font
au niveau d'éducation au niveau de la
culture au niveau des doigts des droits
des femmes c'est une c'est une réalité
on ne prend rien aux plus riches ans et
c'est je raconte je ne prendrai au plus
vite au contraire et et mais justement
c'est il appartient aux gens qui sont
qui ont cet engagement là qui ont 7
cette flamme là de ne pas mollir de ne
pas laisser tomber parce que parce que
parce que c'est du rêve que nous
apportons parce que c'est de la poésie
que nous apportons dans la vie des gens
et et que c'est important en ce moment
il y a le plus grand festival de poésie
du monde c'est le festival de poésie de
médée ligne auquel j'ai eu l'honneur de
colo l'invité de loi en colombie c'est
un festival qui se fait dans un contexte
où on était en pleine play en pleine
guerre de narcotrafic et c'est la paix
n'avait pas encore été signés c'était
est la première que je partis à ce
festival c'était en 2001 ce site il est
parti d'une initiative de poètes qui se
sont dit qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire
contre les bombes et qu'est-ce qu'on
peut faire contre la drogue
et voilà ils ont crié ce festival dans
lequel des centaines pendant et dix
jours et un hôtel qui est plein de sens
d'une centaine de poètes du monde entier
et voilà que le gouvernement décide de 2
voilà de supprimer la subvention qui
kills qu'il accordait à ce festival et
donc les poètes qui sont aussi
malheureusement des militants je dis
malheureusement parce que on aurait aimé
pouvoir ne faire qu écrire et partager
son art mais voilà ils ce sont des
militants qui sont là et qui sont
essayés de en train d'essayer de
mobiliser le monde entier les poètes du
monde entier et les acteurs culturels du
monde entier pour sauver ce festival
parce que parce qu'il apporte
il parce qu'il est vecteur de paix là
est vecteur de paix et si on prend la
peine de
de d'y réfléchir là est aussi peut être
aussi un vecteur économique
malheureusement nous nos responsables
politiquement n'en sont pas conscients
de tourisme culturel voilà il y a des
choses à faire avec la poésie avec les
le spectacle de marionnettes avec le
théâtre avec avec la chanson avec les
cultures il ya des choses à faire et et
c'est dommage que que ceux qui nous
dirigent non non prennent pas conscience
ou en tout cas ne refuse mais est ce que
le travail a été fait auprès de zoos
breydel pour les convaincre de la
nécessité de mise et si on la culture
sur la création artistique comme vecteur
de paix de création de richesses
d'emplois que ça nous ne faisons que ça
ne nous épuisons à versailles nous ne
faisons que ça j'ai été j'ai travaillé
pendant une année au collège de basse
pointe en documentation et jeu entre
midi et deux jallet sur le petit port et
je rencontrais surfer sur son bois flow
là ils me disaient ils me racontaient
qu'ils rencontraient aimé césaire qu'il
m'a montré le banc ou aimé césaire
s'asseyait quand il venait la face à la
mer un poisson voilà et jeux et jeux et
je me disais mais c'est incroyable que
qu'un lieu aussi chargé puis c'est à ce
point laissé à l'abandon
donc j'ai monté un projet qui s'appelait
aimé césaire haï mrc avec tout un
parcours qui qui qui qui débouchait sur
kid qui aurait dû déboucher voilà sur ce
porte qu'on aurait fait revivre avec une
statue grandeur nature d'aimé césaire à
6 drap dans sa posture habituelle sur ce
banc où il avait l'habitude de s'asseoir
et cetera ben je n'ai pas trouvé de je
n'ai pas trouvé le les soutiens dont
j'avais besoin pour mener ce projet ça
pouvait pas être une initiative privée
c'est évident c'est évident mais
imaginez un peu ce que ça aurait pu
apporter du point de vue économique
touristique pour une ville comme basse -
alors que le nord on le sait est
complètement délaissé complètement
laissés à l'abandon
et puis pour la martinique tout entier a
imaginé un circuit avec des touristes
qui viennent la visiter bon voilà c'est
c'est les choses sont possibles il
suffit de deux les rêver et ensuite de
te donner les moyens pour les leur
donner vie des corps les choses sont
possibles il suffit de les revêtir là
vous vous êtes un spécialiste de ferme
arriver notamment les enfants avec les
marionnettes mais en réalité il ne
s'agit pas que de la marionnette à
l'européenne classique parce que vous
avez introduit au fur à mesure notre moi
moi que vous avez des montres attisé que
vous avez quelques uns sont popularisées
en faisant même les adultes et les
enfants ont confectionné eux-mêmes les
marionnettes que quand vous avez inventé
au départ mais king qui vous ont
finalement dépasser alors absolument
parce que souvent les gens me disent bon
c'est pas dit quelque chose de chez nous
à vis de france eq c'était en séance
riche ifo mais j'estime que je fais un
peu de restauration parce que nous
sommes ici quand même d'un peuple
venant d'afrique et la marionnette
africaine jeudi même d afrique ça
existait dans beaucoup de pays d'afrique
est bon pourquoi elle n'a pas traversé
l'océan
alors que le compte à traverser bon là
il ya les suppositions qui sont fait
c'est parce qu'ils n'avaient pas les
esclaves a le droit de fabriquer des
objets puis à l'histoire la religion
parce que souvent la marionnette aussi
était utilisé dans cete cultuel et tout
cela donc ce qui fait que la marionnette
n'a peut-être pas traverser n'est pas
arrivé mais la marionnette quand même
fait partie de l'inconscient antilles
est également donc je fais de la de la
restauration
un pour tous les gens et puis
effectivement les gens l'impression que
la marionnette mon j'aime bien dire où
le bois bois parce que jg pas enlever le
roi du carnaval
mais vu bon au carnaval et les quasiment
plus inexistant puisque même va
normalement c'est un bon bras droit
maintenant c'est un c'est un bois bois
gigantesque en fait je ne sais pas si on
peut toujours utiliser le terme bois
bois pour vale
et donc ça effectivement ça c'est dire
comme on cotise et maintenant que ce
soit les maternelles même dans les
crèches je vais avec les marionnettes
les lycées ma font appel à moi pour
faire des les ateliers tout cela ainsi
que dans les ehpad les grandes personnes
m
les marionnettes et puis c'est aussi bon
c'est quand elle les fabrique c'est
toujours des petites choses qui vous
viennent avant puisque avoir fabriqué
l'eau leur poupée bon moi j'ai un autre
système
mais bon c'est ce sont des activités est
très enrichissante
vous avez misé toutes deux java et
nicolas cage sur une démarche civique
c'est à dire une par anticipation de vos
clients de vos consommateurs en fait à
la fabrication de ce que vous produisez
l'emprunt de parler de marionnettes de
bois les chansons aussi et puis le livre
que vous avez dit que vous êtes bien
connu jal a comme étant quelqu'un qui
fait participer activement
celles et ceux qui souhaitent acheter
vos productions à leur fabrication à
leur élaboration et ça depuis une bonne
trentaine d'années déjà
oui nicolas cage également quand on est
con on dit livre en fête littérature
n'existe que parce qu'il y à des
lecteurs vous pouvez piocher dans du
monde c'est apparemment le lecteur même
qui n'aime pas ce qui n' ya pas de
littérature donc là également bien
rapport j'allais dire un personnel
charnel avec celui ou celle qui en
actifs interactivement est ce que ce
n'est pas risqué aujourd'hui parce qu'on
a une sorte de fragmentation de notre
société
ici comme ailleurs avec une part de plus
en plus importante à l'égoïsme suscité
par les réseaux sociaux avec la vie en
ville avec notre société trépidante
est ce que il ya encore matière à faire
dans ce domaine a impliqué les publics
dans la création de la créativité
artistique
oui oui oui je dis lui on ne peut pas on
peut pas aller contre
voilà contre ce qui est la contre le
progrès entre guillemets alors c'est
comment utiliser justement ces choses là
comme des vecteurs les réseaux sociaux
internet etc
c'est vrai ça ça isole ça
ça ça rompt la communication mais
comment les utiliser pour pour justement
créer du lien quand et ça peut marcher
je dirais qu'il y a des des appels à
l'aide qui sont lancés sur les réseaux
sociaux et vous avez toute une
communauté qui ceux qui se mobilisent à
travers ces réseaux sociaux pour cause
pour une plus un projet pour on a de
plus en plus les cagnottes les cagnottes
pour aider justement les projets
participatifs ont d'ailleurs absolument
et je vais tout cela est amplifié par
parra par les réseaux sociaux dont
l'utilisation est plutôt que de lier que
de les diaboliser et utilisons les
pompes pour continuer à créer d'unir les
premiers rendez vous je parlais tout à
l'heure des rendez vous près de la
préfecture avec vos casseroles et mais
l'appel a été lancé sur les réseaux
sociaux
le comité marine des robes l appel a été
lancé sur les sur les réseaux sociaux
donc on peut on peut et on le fait déjà
maintenant c'est comment l'amplifier
comment comment ne pas perdre cette
dimension humaine des rapports tout
temps tout en bas en utilisant ses
moyens technologiques froid mais c'est à
nous de leur donner vie et chaleur alors
il ya quelque chose
le livre il est temps avant que le livre
noir il entre il englobe beaucoup de
métiers patients l'illustrateur il y a
le maquettiste
il y avait parfois le photographe il ya
des correcteurs il ya des imprimeurs
rien les conjectures
enfin le livre en lui-même une avant
qu'il ne soit livre il passe par
beaucoup de métier donc si le livre
moeurs et a beaucoup de métier je ne dis
pas qu'il faut quand même disparaître
mais qui vont qui ont un manque à gagner
en quelque part je fais une autre façon
chaque fois que fait des animations
aussi avec les enfants je leur dis tous
les métiers qu'il ya autour du livre
comme aussi les diffusions des
distributeurs les livres
oui toutes les bibliothèques tous ces
gens là puis bien sûr il ya le numérique
qu'ils ont mais livre n'est pas encore à
l'antique de la mort parce que bon on a
fait le salon du livre ou au canada en
afrique nos appareils aussi où dans
d'autres pays
il faut voir la production qu'il y à
rien et puis il ya de nouveaux éditeurs
bon moi j'allais était d'ailleurs
j'étais nicolas était mon auteur
maintenant je suis son auteur n'avait
qu'à la fibre on sait bien qu'il ya de
la relève parce qu'il assure manque là
aussi d'un autre pays le manque de deux
maisons d'édition parce que je reçoive
tellement de manuscrits je suppose que
ce sera aussi sont tous mais je salue
aussi la l'ouverture de notre maison
d'édition qui s'appelle les éditions du
sucrier
c'est une jeune martiniquaise aussi et
son nom'' pas ce qui a fait qu'ils ont
ouvert sa maison depuis janvier depuis
janvier 2018
donc ça prouve qu'il ya du travail
encore à faire puisque bon ça se bat
déjà qu'ils vont éditer des lituaniens
et aux jeunes filles et on a bientôt
être l'amour sous ceux pour autant de
maisons d'édition nous avons quand même
quatre cent mille habitants même s'il ya
beaucoup de mal en scène qu'à
l'extérieur environ 105 ap lille en
france
est-ce que ça suffit pour rentabiliser à
montier cet investissement lourd
investissement technique investissement
humain également nicole kadjou qui est
qui veulent commencer je vous pose la
même question à jean lafitte à lyon
avant avant de se lancer on fait une
étude de marché donc cesser c'est la
place il faut la prendre
le aller au plus proche des gens et
et notamment d'un des jeunes parce que
c'est parce que tout commence et donc
produire de la littérature pour jeunes
et ceux qui manquent
alors c'est vrai que les jeunes bon il
on les voit de plus en plus rares - avec
un livre c'est ils ont leur talent au
kindle 2 tablettes l'heure mais il y a
toujours moyen de 2 de retomber j'ai
envie de dire sur de retomber sur un
livre de renouer le contact avec un
livre moi je je je suis une optimiste et
et puis l'objectif le projet de simard
inédit prod ce n'est pas seulement la
technique c'est la carie parce que nous
sommes nous sommes dans ce bassin là et
que nous avons une autre place à prendre
dans ce bassin caribéen cimarron
justement expliqué le terme
si ma demande déjà rappelé ce qui est
sifflé puis pourquoi avoir baptisé notre
édition de ce nom chalon le slogan de
simon eddy progs et les éditions
rebelles et pluriel parce que cimarron
c'est le terme de la caraïbe
hispanophone pour désigner les marrons 1
les marionnettes et les marrons et est
donc j'entends je suis de toute façon
dans une certaine mesure dans une grande
mesure j'ai envie de dire une rebelle et
l'objectif de 2,6 baronne tu es vraiment
de donner la parole à ceux qu'on
n'entend pas habituellement à celle
qu'on n'entend pas habituellement qui
ont des choses à dire qu'ils ont une
sagesse à partager qui ont décollé à
partager qui ont des rêves à partager et
donc c'était cimarron
pour revendiquer justement le caractère
caribe de cette entreprise
edit prod pour la partie édition et prod
pour la partie production puisque nous
avons produisons également de la musique
et le premier opus là et prêts à partir
au pressage c'est un album qui
s'intitule si tellement fond dans le
concept paroles et musique qui m'est
cher nicolas
j'ai la même question que je voulais que
j'ai posée à nicolas cage à l'instant
une maison d'édition c'est quand même un
investissement est ce qu'il y à vraiment
la possibilité de martine qu'étant et
même si nicolas cage a l'intention à
l'ambition de conquérir si je puis dire
la caraïbe pour qu'il y avait une plus
longue expérience en la matière je
suppose que ce n'est pas facile ça n'a
pas été facile tous les jours vous que
d'éditer des livres de libre produire la
lecture oui parce que déjà quand
j'écrivais mamie je mangeais pas fait
d'études de manche et j'avais envie de
fuir vie j'ai fait et puis par exemple
on a grillé un couple les hauteurs de
martinique il ya déjà 50 capes qui se
sont inscrits et j'en connais d'autres
qui ne soit pas encore avec nous vous
avez déjà fait des salons c'est pas
vraiment dit simplement nous attendons
le salon parce que c'est par ces pas les
auteurs qui doivent organiser un salon
m'enfin on a des projets dans ce sens
mais effectivement nous faisons des
rencontres on peut dans plusieurs
communes de martinique avec les auteurs
et dieu seul sait si c'est anna qui
écrit aussi honorable on a besoin de
maisons d'édition parce qu'il ya
beaucoup qui font de l'auto édition rien
de avec le rouleau propres deniers et
cetera ils font la marque ativan chine
est édité aujourd'hui entre guillemets
passionnant beaucoup qui se font aussi
arnaquer 1 quand ils ont besoin de
livres ils ne l'ont pas mais comme on
dit jade est loin gombo gâtés on n'a pas
ça donc il ya toute une niche
effectivement quand j'ai commencé j'ai
fait avec trois hommes déjà aux dépenses
étaient français kréyol et
anglais ça avait fait fuser pas bon
parce qu'il n'y avait pas encore ce type
de l'innovante inique avec lui ai besoin
voilà les livres des albums de coloriage
avec les choses de chez nous toujours
d'aller dans les trois langues dans le
même livre
et tout ça bon ça s'arrête très bien
être très bien fonctionné je ne suis pas
femme n'était pas femme de dossiers pour
aller faire une demande de subvention
pour faire un livre donc chaque fois
c'était les propos de nier de de la
maison
donc ma foi ça marche et bien parce que
ce besoin là et puis ensuite faut pas
croire qu'on reste ici au canada c'est
pas moi qui ai dit bon je vais aller au
canada c'est bon c'est vrai qu'on avait
insisté t on est très très tôt et bc le
canada qui a demandé un coeur qui a
demandé surtout dans la caraïbe ya de
très grands parle d'une salon du livre
de paris mais bon c'est pas encore un
salon du livre a coûté 2,2 ce qu'il y a
par exemple à santo domingo 1 et
appelait de grands salons du livre
absolument la revente par exemple est
grand et je peux vous dire qu'il y a de
la production il y a de la production
vraiment autant en journaux parce que
maintenant il ne reste pas beaucoup de
journaux part je parle aussi de la
presse écrite
1 et puis le monde du livre non c'est
pas tout le monde qui aime lire ou sur
les sous des tablettes a déjà guillem et
puis c'est une autre sensation et à le
papier à le toucher est allé les
archives on voit sa bibliothèque avec
des livres saints sur voilà même si la
pression statique il faut faire
attention à la qualité du livre passe il
ya plein de d'eddy curry des primaires
effectivement qui propose des papiers
vraiment qu'ils ont de très basse
qualité et un an après la libye toujours
les feuilles sont donc pas les gens me
disent oui je suis allé là c'était pas
cher je dis attention pour machete bonta
mathieu bouthier parce que si elle il
faut un petit moment ça va mais si c'est
ce que tu veux garder
et puis dans son temps parce que les
petits livres là qu'on fait avec les
petits papiers après on peut même pas
parler de restauration du livre puisque
le papier trop abîmées on peut pas le
faire regardez qualité de papier tout ça
ça fait partie des métiers qui tournent
autour du livre
la restauration des livres qualité de
papier en fait tout cela bien sûr des
gens disent qu'on protège la forêt quand
on n'imprime pas les livres mais bon pas
de six patients que reste-t-il à
transmettre que j'allais à une cage vous
êtes tourné vers l'avenir vous avez tout
seul sans cesse innover comme je le
disais les messieurs le plan esthétique
sur le plan artistique sur le plan
économique
beau jardin puisque après une trentaine
d'années de votre part en compte comme
très modestement que reste-t-il à
transmettre vous une cage qui vous
lancez aujourd'hui dans une entreprise
mais il ya longtemps quand vous êtes
dans la production vous avez écrit 4e
romance avait écrit de multiples poème
une semaine pas si vous savez comme un
point vous avez déjà écrit ajouté des
pièces de théâtre vous avez produit vous
avez chanté vous êtes vous produisez
régulièrement avec un petit orchestre
qui fait les beaux jours des noctambules
de fort de france
qu'est-ce qu'il faut qu'est ce qui lie à
transmettre à nos enfants nos
petits-enfants
il ya encore tout à coup ce m il y a
quelque chose qui me tient
particulièrement à coeur
sais tu sais il y à la question des
enfants de la jeunesse mais la question
des relations entre les hommes et les
femmes et
et c'est pour porter ma modeste
contribution à cette à cette
problématique là que o2 en dehors des
livres individuelle des auteurs que nous
allons publier sous leur nom de façon
individuelle continuer la pratique des
éditions déontologie parce que parce que
c'est ce sont des espaces jeux quoi les
espaces collectifs où la parole se
partagent ce sont des liens qui se
créent et ça peut donner quelque chose
d'historique donc c'est dans ce sens que
la prochaine anthologie s'intitule
dialogues improbables comme une
tentative de en tout cas comme commun
une contribution tentative de de renouer
le dialogue entre les hommes et les
femmes du pays de la caraïbe et pourquoi
pas du du vaste monde sait voilà que
dans l'espace d'un livre les hommes et
les femmes osent se dire se dire les
choses
se dire les colères les rancoeurs mais
aussi les les espoirs et donc qu'est ce
qu'il reste à transmettre c'est ça un de
mes espoirs c'est vraiment que l'on
arrive à une relation pacifiée entre les
hommes et les femmes de ce pays de 7
caraïbes
parce que on n'ira pas loin tant qu'on
continuera de 2,2 se déchirent idec
simplement dans l'est dans les non-dits
janin pour vous qu'est-ce qu'il faudrait
encore en transmettre comme idée de ce
que la ceni que le monde d'aujourd'hui
est bien y'a pas bien longtemps un
groupe d'élèves d'indicés faisait une
enquête sur moi alors isabelle au sujet
et me poser des questions alors comment
jouer devant un jury dit oui mais nous
nous étions sept enfants n'avaient pas
tous les jouets que vous aviez mais
comment faisiez-vous du gibier mais le
fruit à pain nous nous servons de burin
points
oui le sable c'était le sucre et puis
plein de choses reviennent
comment on faisait en jeu base un beau
combat coque avec les les petits bouts
aujourd'hui des flamboyants en tenez en
faisait en faisait combat coque ou bien
on mettait un clou dans un battant avec
une double bobine de fil on faisait
jouer ou les oublis panthères notre père
nous faisait des on faisait des flûtes
avec les feuilles de papayer avec les
feuilles de papier c'était creux on
faisait les petits trous on faisait nos
flûtes etc tous ces souvenirs là sont
revenus et eux ils connaissent pas ça
ils ont entre 16 et 18 ans et tout cela
oui on a des choses à transmettre un
royaume à manger un fruit à pain twitter
d'un sound etc
oui on a des choses parce que je trouve
qu'il ya eu une espèce de de cassure on
n'a pas parlé
ainsi de ce que nous faisions pas ce que
nous voulions être à la hauteur 10
autres que nous ayons i télé que chacun
et xterra dont il ya ce genre de
transmission là n'a pas n'a pas été fait
l'année en question de l'émission elle
est déjà quasiment fini brièvement vous
êtes présidente de la martinique caisse
ce que qu'elle martinez que voudriez
vous faire parce que l'on nicolas cage
la martinique idéal et elle est dirigée
par une femme
ses pairs par une femme mais papa une
femme omnipotente
elle est il ya là un gouvernement mais
un collège j'ai envie de dire dans la
matinée qu'idéal les hommes politiques
ne sont pas inaccessibles et femmes
politiques ne sont pas inaccessibles et
ils ne sont pas tous puissants ils ont
ils sont sous la halle et toitures
veillance de ceux qui les ont élus et
ils doivent rendre des comptes à ceux et
celles qui les ont élus dans la
martinique idéal bain les hommes et les
femmes
comme je disais tout à l'heure au lieu
de gaspiller l'énergie à ceux à se faire
du mal ben consacre l'énergie ainsi
libérées a à construire ce pays dans la
vente unique idéal mais le les arts
plastiques les arts visuels la musique
le sport autant de place que
l'enseignement du français et des
mathématiques
dans la martinique des allemands
les jeunes apprennent à développer leurs
talents et savent que ben ils ont de
quoi vivre chez eux avec avec leur art
avec leurs talons avec leur savoir faire
quoi d'autre dans la martinique idéal
mais on mange du poisson st moi je la
chine scène dépolluer et dans la
martinique idéal on est ouvert sur la
caraïbe mais on est aussi attentif à
continent source c'est-à-dire à
l'afrique dans la martinique des à
langon commerce avec les voisins de la
caraïbe
ce sont vos premiers clients et nos
premiers nos premiers partenaires
économiques et culturels c'est un peu de
ma martinique ibères merci au niveau
local gens là pour terminer les missions
mêmes questions la martinique idéal que
vous feriez en tant que présidente là je
vous ai lu président de la branche à la
martinique et des ailes
il n'y a pas de parti politique il ya
simplement les démentis ou même
doute que qui se sont qui se sentent
martiniquais moi je ne ferme pas la
porte mais pas de parti politique
puisque quand on entend les discours de
chaque parti tout le monde veut le bien
de la martinique nous bien des
martiniquais donc je ne sais pas
pourquoi il faut se diviser pour le même
le même projet donc pas de parti
politique effectivement et puis que ce
soit un homme une femme bon président de
de la menti ni que je ne fais pas enfin
je suis pas féministe à ce point là
puisque pour moi quand on forme une
femme est par exemple on forme un couple
l'homme et la femme et les enfants
y a pas deux comme on disait avant c'est
moi le chef ex intérêt pour moi ya pas
de chef de deux familles à passer moi
qui porte le pantalon puisque chacun
nous apportons notre
notre savoir faire à l'idéal de du
couple je vois un peu la montée ni comme
ça sans panty son chef de famille c'est
moi qui commande c'est toi la femme qui
fait le ménage et puis et ils l'ont me
va jouer aux cartes et puis va
travailler
nous sommes tous égaux merci je l'aï
nicole cas je devrais participer à cette
émission et met ainsi un procès tu sais
trés d'utopie jeunes aussi je peux
donner un rendez-vous puisque les
auteurs de la martinique
nous serons tous à l'atrium le samedi 24
février de 10h à 17h c é manier dalila
daniel qui organise cela avec la clio
dans le livre service ils seront
l'occasion du revenu largement sur nos
antennes évidemment comme je disais
litres et d'utopie sont nécessaires
puisque les utopistes ont toujours
raison je peux en citer une longue liste
nous arrêterons là pour aujourd'hui pour
cette émission préparée avec fabrice
théodose réalisé par claude une été le
biais à bientôt
merci enfin
face à la première
[Musique]